all right so uh i'm going to tell you
about uh homomorphic signatures and as a
bonus also about homomorphic commitments
uh this is based on a joint work with
sergey and vinod but i'm going to
present things a little differently here
than they are in the paper so first of
all i'm going to focus on this notion of
homomorphic commitments as a good way of
really understanding what's going on in
the signature scheme and also i'll focus
much more on the techniques and the
mathematical tools like it's the
mathematics of crypto workshop so i'll
focus on that rather than the actual end
result i won't even define homomorphic
signatures until about midway through
the talk and the reason is that i think
these tools are actually more even more
important than the application i think
there should be more uses of them so
that's what i really want to convey
okay so uh let's start with the gsw the
gentry so high waters um uh fhe schemes
and uh so this is the one that zika
presented to you and here's just a cheat
sheet what you need to remember from
chica stock so uh the public key is some
matrix a it's an lw matrix so the last
row is a close to linear combination of
the previous rows and the secret key is
just the lw secret the coefficients of
this linear combination and this is the
encryption so to encrypt a a bit x i'm
just going to take the cipher text to be
a times r plus x g where r is a random
matrix with small entries so in zika
stocks it was a 0 1 matrix
that's not actually essentially just
yours once it could be some small
gaussian everything would work just fine
and that will be useful for us later but
it just needs to have small entries and
g is the this gadget matrix the powers
of two matrix that sika showed you so
this is how to encrypt
and i want to now recast the scheme as a
commitment scheme so if you see nothing
much changed on the slide except i got
rid of the secret key and i changed the
names of the procedures
so now imagine that someone comes
generates a public key for the gsw
scheme but then immediately deletes a
secret key there's a trusted third party
we all trust that they did it correctly
and just publishes the public key so now
there's a publicly there's no secret key
well what's the point of that it's
useful as a commitment what's a
commitment let's have some value like i
can predict the outcome of the next
super bowl so uh but i don't want anyone
to know you know what the outcome is or
make life boring but i want people to
eventually find out i have this amazing
predictive power so i'm going to take uh
this value i'm going to essentially
encrypt it i'm going to call that
committing to it no one has the secret
key so no one can decrypt it but i'm
going to remember the randomness so the
randomness of the encryption are
and later after super bowl happens i
want to convince everyone that you know
i predicted things correctly so i'm
going to give people this value r and
the the bid x that i committed to and
people can uh compute you know check
that this commitment was computed
correctly and then they know that the
value i commit to was indeed the value x
okay
so uh this scheme is statistically
binding if i give you this commitment
the value x is uniquely determined
statistically and that just follows from
the correctness of the gsw
encryption schemes if someone actually
had the secret key they could decrypt it
so there's a unique value contained in
the ciphertext of course no one has a
secret key no one can get it and uh
therefore the scheme is also
computationally hiding so if you just
get the commitment you don't learn
anything about the the value x and that
follows from the security of gsw
actually moreover the scheme is even
extractable if you had a trapdoor so if
this person distrusted their party
didn't delete the secret key then they
could even extract out the commitment
there's a trap door that lets you
extract but hopefully no one has it
right that's why we want
binding and hiding
okay there's many ways to do commitments
even from one way functions why would we
use this well there's a nice property
this has which is that it's homomorphic
it has some homomorphic properties
and we can
take a bunch of commitments so
commitments to different values x1 x2
and so on using the same public key a
and we can take the openings to these
commitments and we can do homomorphic
computations on these
okay so uh maybe as a scenario let's say
i didn't just predict the outcome of the
next super bowl i predicted like all the
scores of all the games in the next
season and then um i want to convince
someone that the values i committed to i
actually got correctly let's say the
median score of a game okay so i want i
want to convince someone that i com i
predicted the median score of a game in
the season correctly
so people can do a computation can do a
computation on the commitments and
compute a commitment that's a commitment
to the median score so you value this
median function i can compute
some operation on the openings
and come up with a small opening that
convinces you that this is correct so
there's two
homomorphic evaluation procedure here
one procedure that works on the
commitments this is exactly the gsw
homomorphic operations we saw that zika
presented this is doing homomorphic
operations on previously these
commitments are called ciphertext so
this is the homomorphic operation on the
ciphertext but there's another
homomorphic operation which is the
homomorphic operation on the openings so
i can take the openings the randomness
here and do some operation on that and
come up with an opening
that opens this commitment to the right
value f of x1 up to xn where f can be
again any function
and that just amounts to keeping track
of what's happening with the randomness
of encryption as you're doing
homomorphic operations and we can do
that in the gsw scheme we can keep track
of the randomness
so uh
okay and this is the property i want to
preserve so if you do the homomorphic
computation the commitments and the
openings you get the right value you get
the right opening to the homomorphically
computed command
gsw
uh i think most of them have it i'm not
sure if you do things like bootstrapping
you might lose it actually but
most have it
we'll see why gsw in a little bit
there's some extra properties that has
that are useful
that's a great question
not not really so um
i don't know that these commitments that
anyone can open the initial commitments
so it gives you some sort of binding on
the homomorphic value commitment you can
only open it one way but i don't
actually know that it's that there's
actually any bits that you committed to
that uh
in the beginning
so uh as in i might not have committed
to actual scores of the games uh like
like in the season but if you compute
the median you know that there's only
one value contained there right if you
do the homomorphic computation so it's
not useful for proofs of knowledge
unfortunately
okay
um
so one more thing i want to say is um
what we're concerned about here is that
everything is short succinctness so this
evaluated commitment sure the evaluated
opening is short there's another
property you might want which is that
when i open the commitment to this
homomorphic computation i don't reveal
anything else about the values that i
committed to other than
the value of this function
we're not going to worry about that
we're not the scheme i'm going to
present will not have that property we
can add it uh okay so we can we can add
this extra property that you have
privacy but that's not going to be the
focus so just the main focus that
everything is short the homomorphic
commitment sure the homomorphic opening
is short
okay so let's see how to do this uh this
is just the gsw operation so uh let's
say we want to compute addition well
we're just going to add the two
commitments it's the adding to
ciphertext
and uh
if you want to operate on the openings
you're just going to add the bits and
add the randomness and this is the
equation you have right
so uh
uh so this commitment c plus the correct
opening for it is indeed just the sum of
the two two randomnesses the randomness
just adds up
okay so that that's really easy
multiplication is a little bit harder so
this was the uh homomorphic operation on
the ciphertext that zika showed you so
to create a product to create a
homomorphic evaluation of the product
you just do c1 times g inverse of c2
what happens to randomness here is a
little more complicated this is the new
randomness you get
in green and uh well you can check out
that it works it's this complicated
equation but what's really happening
here is that i'm opening c1 as a r1 plus
x1 g
i'm multiplying that by g inverse c2
well g inverse c2 is just some short
value so i'm going to group r1 and g
inverse c2 together
then i get x1 g times g inverse of c2
the g and g inverse cancel so i get x1
c2 i'm now writing c2 as ar2 plus x2 g
and now again i'm going to group x1 r2
together those are both short values and
i get this thing so i get uh if i'm
grouping all the short values together
i'm going to get this
plus what i want it this is the
commitment to x1 x2
so again we're just keeping track of
what's happening with the randomness as
we're doing gsw operations
okay
so we have this commitment scheme that
has this niceomorphic properties and
actually i want to tell you that this
commitment comes in two different
flavors there's two flavors of this
commitment
depending on how the public is chosen
so the way that the public key is chosen
in gsw the way that suica showed you
it has this structure so a is an lwe
matrix so the first few rows are random
i'm going to write it as b and the last
draw is just
an lw sample it's a close to linear
combination of the previous rows
and so that's how we chose
the public key a and the gsw scheme what
does that give you well
uh
it gives you statistical binding just
because you know correctness of
decryption someone actually had the
decryption key they could decrypt and it
gives you computational hiding by the lw
assumption that's just the security of
gsw
but there's another way we could have
chosen the public key i've just chosen
it uniformly at random
okay now there is no secret key what do
you get then oh sorry one more thing and
it's even extractable using the trapdoor
so if you have s you can actually
extract uh x from the commitment
okay so what if we had chosen a uniform
like random what happens then
well it turns out that now the scheme is
actually statistically hiding
a commitment no matter what bid you
commit to the commitment is just a
random value why is that well a times r
is uh just a left over hash limit
extractor so this is just eight times
our statistically close to uniformly
random
okay so it's statistically hiding
and uh it turns out to also be
computationally binding there's two ways
to show that so one way is you can show
it based on the cis problem the short
integer solution problem directly showed
that that implies it's computational
binding but you haven't heard what the
cis problem is you heard about lw so
there's an easier way or a really easy
way to see from lwe which is well i
could have chosen the matrix this way
you wouldn't have been able to see the
difference and here would have been
statistically binding so it must be the
case that here it's computational
binding and that's actually exactly how
you uh prove computationally hiding here
you say oh i could have chosen this the
public key this way and then it would
have been statistically hiding
right so
yeah
so who is actually picking a
and what happens if they lie uh if if
they lie things are really bad that
there's uh so if they choose it this way
they can extract commitments they can
actually find out what you're committing
to
okay
if they choose it this way there's
another bad thing they can lie they can
open commitments multiple ways so it
turns out that if you choose it this way
it's equivocal uh you can actually
equivocate a commitment you can open in
multiple ways if you have a trapdoor and
that's what i'm going to show you next
but just answer us this question so it's
very important that here whoever chooses
the commitment key this a is doing it
honestly and doesn't have any trapped or
throws you know chooses a randomly or or
this way it doesn't matter which way but
then goes away
okay
so
so that's the next thing i want to show
you that actually if you choose it
randomly then there's a trap door you
can choose the a with a trapdoor that
lets you echo okay that lets you open a
commitment multiple ways
and this is something called related to
the short integer solution trapdoor
which was something introduced by itai
there's a lot of variants of that i'm
going to present one that's closer to
something done by mechanical picard and
so here the goal is to choose a major a
random matrix a statistically close to
random with some trapdoors such that for
any matrix v we can solve we can find
the short r such that a r is equal to v
why
so here i'm not going to be too too
worried about dimensions but v sort of
the the height of v is the same as the
height of r how
uh fat it is doesn't matter you could
just have one vector
then you can just repeat it for each
vector of v
but uh so i'm claiming that if you can
meet this goal you can equivocate on
commitments y
so to open any commitment c any one you
want to any bit x i'm just going to set
v to be c minus x g then i'm going to
solve for r and then i get a r plus x g
equals c which means i open c as a
commitment of x
okay so this is uh this is the goal this
is the trap draw i want and here's the
way to get it so i'm going to choose a
yet another way not exactly randomly not
exactly as lwe but this way so i'm going
to choose the first m over two columns
of a uniformly random and then the last
of m over two comes i'm going to choose
as b r star plus g where r star is some
short
maybe zero one matrix
short randomness and again uh because of
leftover hash limit this is
statistically close to uniform so this
is statistically close to uniform matrix
altogether
okay and my trap door here is going to
be the the knowledge of this this
randomness r star in fact it's useful to
think of it as this matrix negative r
star and identity
and if i write it that way
the trapdoor this way then a times t is
equal to g
okay so now that i have that i'm
claiming i can solve this problem
just uh when i get v i'm just going to
set r to be t times g inverse of v
what happens if i take a times r i get a
t which is g times g inverse of v i just
get v
okay so this lets me lets me solve that
problem let me solve this problem so
this is a way i can equivocate any
commitment at all to any bid i want
but this is actually not quite what i
want this is too weak when i do this
the randomness are i come up with i do i
do find some opening of the commitment
but it doesn't look legitimate it's not
the right distribution i mean i i
managed to open it
but it'll look fishy it's not going to
look like someone who actually generated
the commitment the right way so i
actually want to also match the
distributions that turns out to be a
slightly harder problem so here we want
to do uh some sort of a trap door
opening from the correct distribution
and let me phrase it this way
so the stronger goal is i want to choose
a random matrix a with a trapdoor such
that the following two distributions
will be statistically closed either i'm
going to choose r the randomness r from
some short distribution maybe some
gaussian or zero one random zero one but
some distribution over short entry
matrices and i'm going to compute v
equals ar
versus choosing v uniformly at random
and then somehow opening r using the
trapdoor i want to make sure that these
two distributions are statistically uh
indistinguishable or close
and this should be the case actually
even if you're given the trapdoor so i
want the randomness to come from the
from the opening procedure itself
okay um so um
uh so this is something that i'm not
going to show you how to do it it's
something that was first done by this
work of gentry biker and mike tanathan
uh there's other ways there's a couple
of different ways to do it and most of
the works actually did by carefully
analyzing discrete gaussian
distributions it really relies on the
concrete property of the gaussians uh
there's a different way to do it uh
which we did in this work with vadim
where we do it via rejection sampling
and i think the parameters are all worse
in pretty much all respects but it's
conceptually simpler you don't need to
know about gaussian so that's one reason
i actually like it
okay so this is something i'm not going
to show you but it's something we can do
and how does it relate to the
commitments so now uh in the in the
language of commitments these two
distributions should be
indistinguishable either actually taking
uh
this randomness r from some specified
distribution discrete gaussian or
something specific and computing the
commitment correctly as a commitment a
bit uh to bid x versus just choosing a
uniformly random commitment and then
equivocating it using the trap door to
bid x you shouldn't be able to this
should be indistinguishable you can't
tell which one i'm doing
so the distributions are matching
okay so we have we have this
statistically yeah
okay so uh that's what homomorphic
commitments are so just a brief summary
of the homomorphic commitments this is
uh we have a way of committing to a bid
using some randomness the opening is the
randomness we can have homomorphic
evaluate any function
on the commitments and the openings
these are two different homomorphic
procedures things match up we have two
flavors of these extractable versus
equivocal and depending on how you
choose the commitment key you can get
one version you can get one flavor or
the other
and they are indistinguishable and in
the equioco mode we can open a
commitment using a trapdoor we can open
a commitment to any bid we want
and the distributions match up so this
is what you should remember now i'm
going to use this as a tool
to build
signatures to build something new
okay in fact i want to sort of say that
uh this idea of commitments explains
both homomorphic encryptions and
homomorphic signature if you have the
extractable version what does
extractable mean there's a trapdoor that
lets you let you decrypt that's
encryption right that's fully
homomorphic encryption
and it turns out that in the equivocal
mode you will get
signatures and actually there's a really
nice property here that this commitment
can be set up in one mode or the other
you can't tell the difference they're
indistinguishable i don't have any
application of that so uh if you have
any ideas i think that should have some
applications but right now we have
application one mode and the other mode
but not that you have one commitment
that can work in either
okay so let me now move to homomorphic
signatures and uh let's do the
motivation so here we have some user
alice uh she has some data x think of it
as a big database she wants to outsource
this data to some cloud server
okay she's gonna store x on the cloud
and later either alice or maybe some
other user bob wants the server to
compute some function over this data
some function f over this data
and uh give the output y
okay
so that's the that's the whole problem
and uh
you know there's two things you might be
worried about one is privacy does the
server learn x
and if you want to solve the privacy
problem you can use fully homomorphic
encryption that's what zika spoke about
the other problem is verifiability is
the answer you're getting correct
that's what we're going to be concerned
about here
so uh again
we can look at this problem in two
settings one would be
let's say that the server wasn't
computing function let's say it was just
a channel you were just sending x from
alice to bob so i call that
communication there's two problems
privacy and verifiability so privacy you
know use encryption if you want to self
privacy
if you want to go in the setting where
the server is actually doing con uh
computation well
you need homomorphic encryption
okay let's look at verifiability if you
just want uh communication you need
signatures right that will solve the
just the that problem
now if you want to do computation well
let's just combine the terms we need
some sort of homomorphic signatures
so that's what homomorphic signatures
are let me be a little more specific
okay so in homomorphic signature scheme
the alice is going to have some secret
key sk everyone knows her verification
key i'll call that pk so bob and
everyone knows that the server too
and alice is going to sign some
think of it as a big data set x using
the scheme it's going to come up with
some signature sigma and she's going to
give the server the data x and the
signature sigma
now the server can choose any function f
we want or bob can choose it anyone can
choose f cancer from the sky and the
server can compute this function f of x
and also homomorphically evaluate this
function over the data and the signature
so in this case the data is in the clear
the server knows x
he's computing the function over the
data and the signature is going to come
up with something uh this value sigma fy
i'll call that a certificate that
certifies that y is the output of the
function f computed on alice's data
okay so bob is going to get the func the
output y of this of this computation and
the signature he's and this certificate
this isn't just a signature of y it's
not like uh this actually says that why
why it certifies ys out of the blue it
certifies that why is the output of a
particular function f applied to alice's
data
bob doesn't know alice's data at this
point but he'll be sure that y is the
output of the function applied on
whatever data she signed
okay
and the main property that we want in
this talk again will be just compactness
so everything should be small in
particular this
this certificate should be of some size
which is independent of the size of uh
alice is that or the complexity of the
computation so trivial solution to this
would be just to sign alice's data with
a normal signature scheme then give all
of alice's data and the signatures to
bob and bob can do the computation and
stuff that's not what we want we want
things to be short
okay and so bob is going to want to
verify whether uh this output y is
actually the output of the function f
analysis data x
this verification procedure will
actually consist of two steps so one
step is that bob will do some
pre-processing or processing on the
function f and just the public key
and he'll get something i'll call just a
function specific public key for this
function f
and this step will be computationally
expensive it'll actually
in our scheme ideally it wouldn't be but
in our scheme this will take as much
time as computing f so bob is not start
saving on computation just on this
communication
but the second step uh which will be uh
specific to the actual output and the
data will be to verify uh that y is
correct uh you're just going to take
this pre-processed public key the output
y and the certificate and this step
uh will be efficient it's independent of
the of the runtime the computation um
or of the runtime of f or the size of x
okay so we are getting some efficiency
here but you always have to pre-process
any function you want to verify
yeah yeah exactly so you need
pre-processing
has to be short ekf is short yeah yeah
but you do get this delegation in the
earlier papers pre-processing
it's coming i think next slide will be
comparing to other works so yeah if you
so um
okay
so and the security here is that if f of
x is equal to y the cloud cannot
convince bob of any other output y prime
so you cannot give a certificate
that verifies for some y prime which is
not f of x that's the security
there's some additional features you
could ask for that mostly i'm just going
to mention them here i won't discuss
them much more but for example here
alice in this scenario l just signs one
data set x one database you could ask
that she signs many different databases
right and maybe she has like a data set
of her employer employee salaries and
some other information about her company
and she you know she signs different
ones at different times so we can do
that as well uh at that point alice has
to just each time she signs the data
such as to give it some label and when
you verify computation you need to know
which data set this computation is
supposed to be evaluated on so you need
to have that label in mind when you're
verifying
another feature you might want is
context hiding some sort of privacy
feature which is that if you get the
certificate that wise the output of of
this computation analysis data you
shouldn't learn anything else about
alice's data other than the output y
so it should preserve some privacy
and again that's something that we can
do but i'm not going to i'm not going to
talk about it
okay um so um the idea of homomorphic
signatures has been around for a while
uh and uh most of the past works on
homophilic signatures looked at the case
of linear functions so they were able to
just do you know you had some
coefficients and you were able to do
like an inner product of else's data x
with some vector of of your knowledge
uh and so the good news is we know how
to do that from nice assumptions like uh
by linear assumptions rsa short integer
solution and lattices
if we wanted to go beyond that there was
this really beautiful work by bon and
freeman that showed how to do boundary
degree polynomials so really constant
degree polynomials and this was based on
the ideal short integer solution problem
so a lattice problem and the random
oracle model
uh there's another work by catalano
i think fiora and varinci which
therefore also bound to degree
polynomials but got rid of the random
oracle at the cause of using multilinear
maps and so in this talk i'm going to
show you how to do all circuits it's
going to be a level scheme so the sizes
do grow with the depth of the circuit
but nothing else
and uh we're going to do it just based
on the short integer solution problem or
the lw problem actually we're going to
do black box using homomorphic
commitments that are equivocable
the other results and they have to
invest so much time in the presentation
like
yeah
all of these results
everyone
they're all on equal footing yeah
i think that's the next next next slide
yeah so there are other solutions to
this problem uh like give us pointing
out other things you can do
so one is cs proofs of snarks that were
defined by mikali
um so this is a way to take any
complicated np statement and give a very
short proof that proves it and if you
have that you there's a very nice simple
solution to this problem so ellis is
just going to sign her data with a
classical signature and then the server
if he wants to convince bob that y is
equal to f of x uh the f of x is equal
to y for this for the data x that alice
signed he's just going to create this cs
proof or snark that certifies this
so it's an np statement there exists uh
some data x and some standard signatures
such that f of x is equal to y that's
what he's going he's going to give a
short proof of that
to bob and bob is just going to verify
the proof
okay so here you actually need
sustain non-interactive arguments of
knowledge it's a pretty strong
assumption so it uses non-standard
assumptions like random oracle model
or knowledge of exponent type
assumptions and in fact these are these
are essentially there's some evidence
that you cannot do it without without
these types of strong assumptions in
fact for the here you actually need
arguments of knowledge there's evidence
that these might not even exist in the
most general case so you need some very
targeted assumption in order to clear
the the negative results
there's also been a lot of works and so
that's the that's the part that we're
going to get rid of in this work we're
going to do things just from lwe or cis
there's also been a lot of works on
memory delegation which is another
another uh
way of doing solving this problem and
there you can actually even sometimes
get rid of the pre-processing get uh
efficient solutions where bob never
works as hard as the value in the
program the main difference is that all
of these solutions require some
interaction there's some challenge
response protocol that bob has done with
the server whereas we're talking about a
completely non-interactive solution
solution there's really a fixed
certificate that certifies the output of
the computation
so um
so that that's the main difference there
okay so the theorem is that there exists
a homomorphic signature scheme for
arbitrary uh programs you're going to
represent in the circuit
where um the size of the certificate is
going to grow
with the depth of the circuit and the
security parameter but not with the size
of the circuit or the size of the data
and the security would be just assuming
the short integer solution or lwe
problem
in fact uh equivocal homomorphic
commitments
there's a caveat
we're going to need to assume that all
parties have access to very large public
random string
as large as the size of the data that
alice is signing
okay in the oracle model random oracle
model you can get rid of it maybe you
can just pretend that the digits of pi
are good enough or sun spots or
something like that but that is a caveat
here
so the random string is it reusable i
mean let's say
completely reusable everyone uses the
same one
it's just just random bits in the sky
exactly yeah do you use that for
correctness
uh well for correctness you can use pi
rather than a random string for security
you need it to be actually random
can a malicious generator
do bad things
yes
yes
if the string is generally maliciously
bad things can happen
okay so as a warm-up let's just do
something really pathetic i want yeah so
the very fire does not have to read this
public stream
the verifier does have to be the public
string
yeah
yeah in the so remember there's that
pre-processing stage that does take as
long as the data so he needs to do it
during the pre-processing stage
daniel is there any in terms of the
caveats of pre-processing and the large
random string is there any evidence that
these are inherent so the pre-processing
is inherent if you're doing it at the
level of circuits rather than turing
machines because just reading the
compute circuit takes as much time as
evaluating
you need either the it
string no
no
not not as far as i know
um
okay
so um
so let's as a warm-up let's do something
really pathetic really simple just a
one-time one-bit signature from an
equivocal commitment
okay i think this is uh this is
well-known but uh i don't have a good
reference so someone please tell me we
know what the right reference is so here
the public parameters are just going to
be a random commitment not to any [ __ ]
just totally random to choose it from
the space of commitments at random the
verification key is going to be the
commitment key
so um and the signing key is going to be
the equivocation trap door
okay
and uh to sign a message x
we're just going to use the signers
going to use the trap door to sample an
opening to this commitment that opens it
as a commitment to x
okay that's it that allows you here
you're just signing one bit you can only
do it one time that's it
okay and uh this scheme is some nice
selective security in the case of one
bit it doesn't matter selected but not
but it's actually useful to think of it
as selective so if the adversary tells
you what bid he's going to ask you to
sign ahead of time you can just set the
commitment to be the commitment of the
correct bit so you can actually program
it in the public parameters
without knowing the trap door
and now if the adversary is able to
forge come up with a signature of the
incorrect bit well you just broke the
binding property of the commitment right
you committed to one value the adversary
gave you the open the commitment to the
other value you broke binding
that's it
okay and these distributions are
indistinguishable by the equocation
property we have whether you generate
the commitment just at random and then
later
open it using the location trapdoor
versus actually committing to the bid
ahead of time those are the same
distributions
okay what if you want to do many bits
still one time but now many bits well
now i can put many random commitments in
the public parameters and uh to sign
like a long message x1 xn you can just
use the trapdoor to sample openings for
each one of these commitments to the
correct values you want to sign so here
the public parameters grow with the
number of bits you want to sign but the
public key and the verification key the
verification key and signing keys stay
short those don't grow
okay
and this is the main idea we're gonna
use to construct the fully homomorphic
commitments
so the fully homomorphic commitments
we're going to have these long public
parameters which are just
fairly homomorphic signatures which is
going to have this long public
parameters which are commitments to just
randomly generate commitments the
verification key is the commitment key
the signing is the equivocation trap
door
to sign a long message x1 xn you're just
going to open each one of the
commitments to the right value
and now the homomorphic operations work
as follows
so
if you want to compute
some homomorphic function over the
signatures
that's essentially the homomorphic
operation over the openings of the
commitment signatures are openings to
commitments
okay so you're just going to evaluate
this function over the openings and get
some certificate which is just an
opening rf
uh
so well just to some commitment to the
homomorphic value commitment the
verifier
is going to run the homomorphic
computation so the signer the the
evaluator runs the homomorphic the cloud
i guess runs the homomorphic computation
on the openings
the verifier is going to run the same
the homomorphic computation on the
commitment so this pre-processing of a
function f is going to run this uh
homomorphic computation over the
commitments that are in the in the
public parameters and come up with the
commitment uh well for this function f
okay and how do you actually verify that
well you just check that the commitment
matches that this homomorphically valued
opening is a correct opening to the
value y
for this homomorphically evaluated
commitment value
okay so you just check that the things
match up
and uh why is this secure well you can
show that this is at least selectively
secure so selectively secure if you know
what data is going to be signed ahead of
time so
not in the in the actual scheme but in
the proof of security the adversary
tells you what data he'll want you to
sign ahead of time well if he does that
you can actually set these commitments
uh in the public parameters to be commit
so in the reduction you can set these
commitments in public parameters to be
the commitments of the bits that the
address is going to want to see signed
then you can give him the signatures
just by giving giving this randomness to
the to the adversary if the adversary
manages to come up with a function f and
some forged signature so that's an
opening of this commitment cf the
homomorphic value commitment to some
value y prime which is not the correct
output of the computation
well you can compute the correct
signature the correct opening of that
commitment to the correct value i and
now you have uh
now you open the commitment in two
different ways so you broke the binding
property of the commitment
okay
so this shows you that this scheme
already has uh selective security
yeah
yeah
okay so uh that that's really the scheme
so that this gives you selective
security um
so
well there
it is a one-time signature scheme so
here else is just signing one data set
but different people could have totally
different public keys and signing keys
they wouldn't interact interfere with
each other but then the proof of
security you need to set cis to be
to be equal to certain values
so you would just guess who's going to
be attacked yeah exactly you just guess
who's going to be attacked
so if cf is uniform how does it depend
on f
see sorry see the these commitments
so no cf is the homomorphic evaluation
of the function f on these commitments
in the pub in the in the sky
it's not uniform sorry
it cannot be open to anything
um
that's right so so i mean in the
security proof i'm not opening cf to the
wrong thing right i'm opening these
original i'm well actually in the in the
scheme is opening commitments
incorrectly the proof is creating
commitments correctly
i know that's a confusing part so the
actual scheme is using that location of
the commitments right to sign you open
the commitment to whatever value you
want to sign in the proof we're going to
set the commitments correctly to
actually be commitments to the value
that will be signed and we don't know
the trap door
nevertheless if the adversary forges he
gives he breaks the binding property so
without knowing the trapdoor we manage
to break binding
that's the reduction
this is just for one time
one time as in
you you only sign one data set yeah
uh so let me mention a couple of
extensions so you know we started with
something very simple you can just sign
one data set it has selective security
so if you want full set security not
just selective the address say doesn't
isn't nice and doesn't tell you what
what data he's going to want to see
signed ahead of time
there's a nice way to go from the
selective to full via a notion called
chameleon hash
in order to do it with homomorphic
signatures we need some sort of
homomorphic chameleon hash and that
turns out to be exactly a homomorphic
equivocal commitment so we have that so
sorry i'm gonna i'm not gonna spend more
time on that it's just for those who
know what chameleon hash actually is
if you want to assign multiple data sets
so not just one data set there's a
really easy way to do it which is you're
just going to use a standard signature
scheme not a homomorphic one each time
you want to start it assign a new data
set you're just going to choose a
totally fresh pub
verification key and sign-in key for the
home morphic signature scheme and then
sign the verification key of the
homomorphic scheme with the regular
scheme okay so that just sort of a
hybrid uh signature type thing
uh and lastly i just want to mention
this context hiding property so we want
to make sure the certificate only
reveals the compute the result of the
computation and nothing else
well one simple way to do it generically
is just with nzx so instead of actually
giving the homomorphically computed
signature you'll give a non-interactive
zero notch proof that you know it
so here you don't need snarks or
anything right this is uh the statement
is short
uh so that that's a generic way to do it
it turns out that there's actually a
nice way to do it for a specific scheme
just using the properties of lattices um
so just the the underlying gaucher but
you don't need any extra assumptions
okay uh so some big open problems are
how do you remove the large public
parameters it'd be nice to get rid of
that can we remove the dependence of on
on the depth of the circuit uh or do
bootstrapping um we don't know how to do
bootstrapping for this scheme we know
how to different encryption doesn't
quite work for the signature exactly
because there's no secret key to encrypt
there's no decryption key
and one more problem the guy alluded to
is can you do something where there's no
pre-processing everything is efficient i
think that would require vastly
different techniques because it would
really you would need to work with the
idea that the computation is a turing
machine rather than a circuit so that
would really be different than what
we're doing here but it'd be interesting
to do that
okay
it is possible to hide
the operations that were done uh uh on
the uh
on the inputs
uh is it uh do you get it for free or uh
what is the cost of achieving this
oh that's essentially so the cut this
this context hiding thing it's not
you're not hiding the operations because
the verifier needs to know what
computation is supposed to be checking
you're hiding the data other than the
output of the computation uh and that's
essentially for free yeah
in this case in this case for this
scheme i mean the scheme is already
pretty inefficient but it's you know you
get like not much more inefficient
that's a good question so yes we
actually can
it's not in the paper but there's
actually an easy way to do it so i'll be
happy to tell you
we'll resume at 11 30. let's thank
everybody
you